all right let's get into audience
questions for the week I think some of
these will be informative and some may
also anger many many people the first
one is hey David we've heard about you
disclose your Tesla stock ownership
although not recently but I guess that's
because you haven't been talking about
Tesla can you please disclose all of
your investments and thus possible
conflicts of interest okay so let's
let's assume that this is a good faith
question the reality is I own tiny
pieces of thousands and thousands of
companies through mutual funds I
couldn't tell you what they are I have
like the u.s. total stock market index
fund which owns you know pieces of a
broad-based series of companies as
possible I have a total international
stock mutual fund I couldn't possibly
tell you what companies I own in little
pieces through those but if I don't know
about them presumably that's not really
what's at issue here I think what people
are asking is what individual stocks do
I own now I'm gonna tell you every
individual stock I own because it's only
like six stocks but I want to make clear
number one I'm not giving any financial
advice here and number two I don't even
recommend individual stock investing for
the most part over a long period of time
most people particularly when they're
only investing in a few stocks are very
unlikely to actually do better than just
investing in mutual funds over the very
long term unless you get extremely lucky
very few people are actually that great
at picking stocks I think that what you
want to really be doing is dollar-cost
average regular investment program into
mutual funds at the lowest fee possible
there are funds out there that charge I
think there are actually some absolutely
zero fee funds now most of the ones I
have I pay zero point five point zero
five percent or 0.1 percent annually as
a fee and that's it okay so what
individual stocks do I own I own Tesla
as many of you know I sold I invested in
Tesla years ago and I sold half of it I
believe it was last year or the year
before something like that so I owned
Tesla I owned Netflix I have owned
Netflix for a very very long time
and I actually had forgotten that I own
Netflix but that one is another one that
I own I own Google I've owned Google for
a very long time and I own Amazon I
bought Amazon years ago and those are my
four like if you look at those four
those have done really really well
they're probably multiple times higher
than where I bought them don't really
pay super close attention to what
they're doing I own Sirius Radio and
I've owned it for a very long time and
it really hasn't done much for a very
long time I got into serious stock I'm
trying to think not ten years we will
see Sirius started 13 years ago maybe
I've owned it for nine nine or ten years
or something like that it I don't think
it's done super well over that period of
time and lastly I got in on the blue
apron IPO and I completely lost my shirt
I think they're currently under
class-action lawsuit for having lied
about their revenue when we had blue
apron as an advertiser I invested in
their IPO and I think it's lost like 90
percent of its value or something like
that there was I think there was a
reverse stock split actually it was just
horrible this is why I mostly don't
invest in stocks those are the stocks
that I own if as as just looking at
those six companies it's a completely
unbalanced stock portfolio most of my
money is in mutual funds period so there
it is now as far as the disclosure thing
you know every when I used to talk about
Tesla every time it would come up I
would say full disclosure I own shares
of this stock and then eventually people
in the audience wrote to me and said
David you know number one you don't own
that much of the stock and number two
nothing you say is conceivably going to
move the stock like me reporting on
someone was you know hitting a crash or
so who knows it's not going to move the
stock so you don't have to disclose it
every time you mention it but then I
stopped disclosing and a few people
wrote in saying David it is completely
dishonest and a terrible terrible thing
of that that you're doing by no longer
disclosing the Tesla ownership so I
don't know listen I mean when when I
mentioned Howard Stern I don't mention
that I have serious stock when I
recommend a Netflix series I don't
mention
you know that I own that I just I just
don't think it really matters I'm not a
major shareholder and the show is not
going to move the stock price but you
tell me should I be disclosing stock
ownership every time I mentioned these
companies